avec david levine ex ministre délégué à
la santé sous le gouvernement de
monsieur landry ancien président et
directeur général de l' agence de la
santé et des services sociaux de
montréal bonsoir monsieur levine d'eau
soir alors ce que je viens d'évoquer ce
ne sont pas nécessairement des problèmes
nouveaux mais dites nous l'ont valeo au
coeur de la sphère qu'est ce qui
distingue le réseau anglophone du réseau
francophone dans le milieu de la santé
c'est pourtant le même syndicat
je pense c'est principalement une
question de culture et d'attitudes à
l'intérieu de l'organisation dans les
milieux anglophones par cette pipe 1,25
un conte à une pénurie d'infirmières
moins s'était clairement réalisé les
nécessités de hambach qui les
infirmières d'entraînement de l'ensemble
de gestion de l'organisation donné une
route alain permière chef prépondérant
dans l'hôpital qui est souvent pas le
corps dans nos hôpitaux francophones et
honnêtement traiter les infirmières
comme des vrais professionnels pour
juste des gens qui sont pays d'1 ou à à
la remorque des médecins est ici cette
attitude influence beaucoup millions de
fans sur leurs gardes l'urgence on prend
1,10 urgences de l'hôpital juif c'était
une question de gestion l'eau vous avez
des modèles de gestion
différents que dans le réseau à quoi
donc des modèles d'ingestion si je
comprend bien qu'ils permettent plus de
souplesse passe quand on dit entre
autres que dans les établissements
anglophones le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire le fameux thé seo est
nettement moins présent
et est moins présent parce qu'ils
organisent leurs horaires il en est de
flexibilité dans l'horaire et y prévoir
des trous et il s'organise du monde
disponible alors c'est vraiment une
question d'organisation
à l'intérieur de l'établissement ya
peut-être aussi le fait qu'ils aient
moins de taux de roulement vous savez un
taux de roulement c'est le nombre
d'années que personne garde son poste si
on me satisfait on va garder plus
longtemps si on a un set ce fait si on
ne peut pas traiter comme on malades
traités on va changer parce que le nom
d'hôpital on va changer une pause pour
ainsi hennessy alors dans ce sens là le
roulement dans le réseau francophone est
plus élevé que le roulement dans les
réseaux anglophones à la raison et la
foi nous on privilégie aussi un peu plus
si je comprends bien le temps partiel
face au temps plein mais a quand même
c'est un réseau le réseau anglophone qui
fait face aussi donc à la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre là il me semble est la
pandémie il ya 4301 fermé en ce moment
dans le réseau qui manquent d'ici cinq
ans au total on prévoit 26 mille
infirmières manquantes anguilles mais
alors dans quelle mesure le réseau
anglophone et épargnées par la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre avec le portrait que
vous nous dresser là je pense que cette
réputation dans le milieu anglophone
arrive parce que la grande majorité des
infirmiers dans le milieu anglophone
sont francophones sont pas anglophones
alors dans ce sens là quand une
infirmière quittent l'école l'université
de montréal à titre d'exemple ont le
choix
mais peut-être parmi leurs collègues
vadim et je dois je dois m'appliquer à
quel environnement
alors il choisit alors peut-être pénurie
est moins bien dans les milieux
anglophones que francophones pour la
question d urgence qu'on a parlé tout à
l'heure c'est clairement sérieux
première fois que moi je vois vraiment
hélas ses 40 ans que je suis dans le
réseau on a eu des époques où seulement
deux médecins pour couvrir la nuit et
sont à régler ça avec les syndicats au
médical mais d'avoir autant de manque
d'infirmières
tête obligé d'arrêter les les chirurgies
qui était un élément de la pandémie mais
vraiment pas un élément qu'on a fait
souvent à 20 à la situation au sérieux
il faut donner en urgence une priorité
il faut que ce soit le focus à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital et qui est une
personne à l'urgence tellement haut
niveau est tellement vague influencé
autorités qui sont capables de commander
ce qu'il a besoin dans l'hôpital c'est
le code le milieu anglophone c'est pas
le corps dans les milieux francophones
et en terminant quelques mots parce que
le temps file malheureusement monsieur
levin dans quelle mesure à long terme ce
modèle rappelons le est anglophone est
applicable aux réseaux francophones ou à
l'ensemble du réseau est ce que vous y
croyez
moi je crois qu'il est pas ce que c'est
c'est un modèle qui qui qui est pensée
sur les relations interpersonnelles
entre l'administration et les
professionnels de santé moi je crois
c'est possible je sais que les mesures
de messieurs abeba idées en offrant des
mesures stimulant pour les infirmières
je rappelle une phrase que vous avez
prononcé en 2015 monsieur levine un
hôpital ne peut pas se gérer comme une
chaîne de montage merci beaucoup de tous
merci beaucoup
d'entretien et bonne soirée